[Música]
no los abandonaremos prometió emanuel
macro el presidente francés anunció que
tal como a los franceses los afganos que
colaboraron con francia también serán
evacuados
es nuestro deber y nuestra dignidad de
proteger los que nos ayudaron
intérpretes choferes cocineros y otros
conductos un número de afganos
defensores de derechos humanos artistas
periodistas y activistas están
amenazados hoy por lo que hicieron
nosotros los ayudaremos desde dos de
acuerdo con el ministerio de asuntos
exteriores francia recibió a más de 600
colaboradores afganos y a sus familias
desde que los combates se intensificaron
en mayo elevando la cifra a más de 1300
personas desde que las fuerzas francesas
se retiraron en 2013 sin embargo sacar
una visa francesa no ha sido fácil para
todos a principios de este año france24
conoció a nacer un intérprete para la
armada francesa a quien le negaron la
visa francesa cinco veces él huyó del
país por temor a represalias del grupo
talibán
me curo la cara para que no me
reconozcan
cambio de casa cada dos tres o seis
meses
por el momento solo quienes estén en
peligro por haber colaborado con el
occidente fueron elegibles para una visa
francesa antoine hoy y un abogado que
representa a afganos que trabajaron para
francia dice que el anuncio de macrón
podría facilitar las cosas para otros
por primera vez el presidente dijo que
teníamos que proteger a los que ayudaron
a las tropas francesas
y eso es algo que nunca habíamos
escuchado por primera vez francia dejó
claro que iba a protegerlos
parís envió refuerzos hacia el
aeropuerto de kabul para acelerar el
proceso de evacuación incluyendo la
emisión de visas para los afganos que
buscan la seguridad con desespero